it did go better for the new england
patriots on sunday
bill belichick cam newton and company
getting the 10-point win over the miami
dolphins
uh and and and here's the thing we saw
15
rush attempts from cam newton on sunday
but that doesn't mean we're going to see
15 a week we know how the patriots are
you've said this all along
they never have a system they have a
game plan that is designed
for whoever they are facing each week on
either side of the ball
here is bill belichick from yesterday
talking about
what by all appearances was an entirely
new offense with a new quarterback in
place serious
oh all right uh we'll keep going uh
chris you took a look at the film
oh there now oh here we go now we have
it here's bill belichick
better late than never well we always
try to do what's best for the team to
win
and um you know everything we've
done for the last uh 20 years and
rightfully so has been
for tom brady it was for tom brady um
everything was dedicated to him other
than the games that he didn't play in
like
um you know when castle played
um or jimmy and then jacoby
um when brady was suspended so you know
there were times when we we had to plan
differently but
uh you know when you your starting
quarterback has uh
things that he's good at are things that
you can take advantage of then i think
you try to take advantage of
how about how about the shiv in the ribs
there when brady was suspended the
gratuitous reference
to deflategate by the guy who made it
clear i had nothing to do with any of it
and he came out of that episode
unscathed
well yes i again i don't think he's try
i don't know i mean again i don't think
bill's the type that's trying to take
any shots
he's just answering the question there
and trying to say it i don't know what
to say probably didn't need to explain
why he wasn't there we all know
you're right you're right he didn't need
to go there uh
but i think the point nonetheless what
he said
is very real i mean there's nobody ever
been better at formulating game plans
around
what we need to do to put our players in
the best position
to be the best they can be and then what
we need to do
within those confines that makes sense
that
can beat this particular team this week
and nobody they're the masters the jedi
masters whatever you want to call it i
mean belichick
and then now josh mcdaniels of course on
the offensive side of the ball
it was it was the most fun game i
watched on film yesterday mike and i
watched i think four and
offense of a few other ones so i bought
watched a bunch but
just what they got there the personnel
sets
the formations all the movements before
the snaps
and then the schematical binds they're
putting you in
with the run game you know coupled with
things in their pass game that they've
always had because of brady and things
like that to where
it's a special formula it's gonna put
seattle in a big bind this week
mcdaniels and belichick have come up
with something that fits cam newton
and is going to force defense's hands
and make them do
and play defenses that they don't
necessarily want to play
because of the variety of personnel's
formations and different schemes
especially in the run game the patriots
throw at you
then there's nobody better at marrying
their run game with play-action passes
they make it look exactly the same
they're the best that there's ever been
at that and that's scary with cam
because at his defense you're just going
i don't know where it's coming from are
they running up the middle is cameron up
the middle they're running the option on
the edge
is it the bootleg is it the play action
pass is it
is it a drop back you know throw the
bomb down the field
and like we talk with all great offenses
they're going to make you defend
every inch of the field and that's where
they're going to be scary
uh and one of the things i was told
going into the season
josh mcdaniels incorporating the
playbook that he devised for tim tebow
10 years ago how much of that kind of
stuff the tebow
mania stuff from 2011 did you see show
up yesterday
for cam newton and the the the patriots
when you looked at the film
a lot of it i mean again i think it's
more advanced and a little more nuanced
than cutting edge because mcdaniels
didn't really get to play with tebow and
get deep into it
but with cam newton there them knowing
he's the starter off training camp
wow think about the first touchdown cam
newton had mike the run to the right
i mean nobody touched them they they
schemed it up
and they're gonna pose issues that way
third
downs empty formation nobody in the
backfield what the left guard
pulls and cam newton follows it like
it's the counter tray or the
the power trap and runs for a first down
on third and five
so there's so multiple and what they can
do and if they get you in that third and
four or third and five area
they're almost unstoppable because of
everything they have
and then what the the biggest thing is
where they're gonna put you in by and
they're gonna like i said make you play
defenses
that you don't want to play they're
going to probably handcuff you to the
degree because you're going to go
as we talk about like lamar jackson's to
the world oh
if we bring this blitz over here and go
for it if they call that quarterback
design
run the other way we're screwed we're
outnumbered they're going to have so
many blockers cam newton's going to run
40 yards before he gets touched
that's going to simplify defenses and
then here's to me what really jumped out
mike
miami started going wait this cam newton
stuff is really tricking us
let's play man-to-man and leave our two
linebackers in the box one will take the
running back
and then the other one's got cam newton
well
that's easy to say until new england
shifts the formation and everybody moves
a different way and the back moves and
all of a sudden they say
set hut and the defense is still talking
but the other thing that's brilliant
about it is
if you want to play that style and play
man-to-man
again yeah it might help you to defend
the cam newton run
but let's not forget they got all the
tom brady man-to-man
pass beaters pick plays and all those
things too so as soon as miami kept
doing that
new england was like oh well hey we
didn't forget how to do all those cool
drop back passes we used to have
and they found ways to get guys open
that way and uh
i was as you could tell very excited
about what i saw
the one concern i continue to have based
upon the flashes i saw because i was
watching nine games at once i haven't
gone back and watched the patriots game
yet
but cam newton was getting hit yeah and
you know we we see cam
he's a statue he's a giant he looks
indestructible but we know from
experience he can get injured because he
has right
bill belichick was asked yesterday about
this reality that when you run a guy 15
times there's a chance he's taking hits
that's going to cause him to get hurt
here's belichick on that dynamic
of trying to protect cam newton i think
those numbers are
with all due respect i mean i think
they're a little bit skewed the defense
if they played a certain way they could
you know put the ball in whoever's hands
they want to if they want
you know if they really wanted to clear
who's going to get the ball so
we'll see how teams play us going
forward on those type of plays if we run
those again i don't know we'll
you know do what's best each week based
on the team that we're playing and
and how we feel like we you know can
attack them
and what he was specifically referring
to was the fact that there were 15 runs
from cam newton
on option plays right so it wasn't a
designed
run to cam newton in shotgun and he
takes off to the left or he dives up the
middle
it was he gets the ball and he reads his
keys and he decides am i keeping the
ball am i handing the ball off and it
very well could be against the seahawks
yes
if they begin swarming to him it's the
handoff instead exactly
it's somebody else with those 15 runs
not him and that's belichick's point
it wasn't let's just go throw caution to
the wind and run this guy 15 times
that was what the defense gave us and
that's what we took yeah that's exactly
right
it just it presented itself and just off
the top of my head and not that i marked
it down
but like the run plays that were
legitimate like okay
cam newton's definitely getting the ball
it's probably
i want to say maybe three four runs
maybe it was five
you know you saw that fourth and one
there was the third and five i explained
there was maybe one or two other ones
and mike i'm interested when you go back
and be become ron jaworski and watch the
film of the game too
right seriously though i thought the one
thing that i looked at
other than maybe two runs out of the
other
you know 13 runs or whatever it was he
did a very good job of
getting down or getting skinny and
falling to not let anybody just hit him
squarely
so i do think he was aware of it is what
i'm saying
and you're right it's it's going to be
living dangerously if he has to run the
ball
that many times but they're dangerous
that way
they'll protect them the right way and
i i think the the other thing too is
this puts everybody on notice now
anybody that watched the game
the teams that play them here going
forward are going to go whoa okay they
can burn us with all this quarterback
stuff we got to play something different
and i don't know if all those
opportunities will necessarily present
themselves and new england will be ready
for plan b
this week for teams to stop the cam
newton you can guarantee they'll have
all the things ready going
i think they're going to adjust this way
to stop cam newton
so let's have this this and this ready
for that adjustment
and this is the broader dance that
happens during a football season the 16
game season is like the 15 round fight
that they don't do anymore because of
the horrific brain damage that happens
in the final three but you set up
early what you're gonna do late it
happens in a game it happens in a season
and part of the setup for future
opponents is what you're putting on film
now and so you get them to think this is
what you are
and you give them a look and they think
from their own film study this is what's
coming and that's not what's coming
exactly they're going to get you a
different way
and the simplest and most basic way to
do that is that that option that's why
the rpo
works that's why the option works if you
can get the defense to commit
one way and you can have that cool
enough of a head to make a good decision
and
and uh hand the ball off or keep it then
then it's effective but i still worry
about cam newton getting hit
worry about every quarterback getting
hit it's basic physics it's basic
science
the more a guy gets hit the greater the
chance he's going to get hurt and they
just need to be careful because everyone
believes this guy's indestructible
including cam newton himself despite
everything
he's been through hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports